charging
uh north northeast of us 40 of us who
where
on your compass
around
are they're around us
is there like ambient reflective light
if i point it at the ground does that
help you guys
i honestly don't know
well
so it doesn't trigger them if you
pointed at their uh these guys are right
next to each other maybe we just ignore
them i i say why bother right why risk
it yeah that's true there's a door right
over there is it is it
is it an alarm door or can we just go i
know it's just a regular scan
all right this is the love of god what
am i inside of
okay there we go i don't like the goops
on the ceiling
yeah they're so gross that spells
something bad there is a teacher dude
right through the door
right there not not like on it but like
five meters inside the door okay yeah
it's not an alarm we just do it
that's what i think sure sure sure
all right we're good we're good we're
fine oh [ __ ] hey look guys
it's the tangible oh boy well sniper
well no you can't there there's another
one in here as well and we can't shoot
because we've got bigs behind at least
it'll be brightly lit so we can see oh i
don't know careful careful careful
careful careful that's fine that's fine
oh this is bad nah that's fine this is
as bad as it gets i got this guy
easy the tent pulses out okay
the only one the only one on the scanner
right now is tentacle boy here's a good
alamo and if we get in trouble i think
it's a controlled like one staircase we
could fight for them nothing else on the
scanner other than uh our tentacley
friend okay
should be able to grab him then oh wait
there's a there's a white uh there's one
over uh
forty five yeah it's like bigger
yeah i see him i'm next to him but he's
fine
can we spear the tentacle he's gonna
keep coming this way can you i can try
and get out on him
yeah i'm gonna go in for him now
nice good okay we just got this big
right one big two there's two dots over
there i don't know what they are one of
them is big it might be two bigs
i only oh no one biggest small right
there it's a shooter
uh guys oh my god what the hell happened
he just woke up
figgis popped okay
all right let's see are the ones behind
us pissed off yes the ones behind us are
pissed off singing now all right i'm
gonna let you try to snipe them yeah i'm
gonna try and get them as they come in
the door okay here's one
dead
all right give me a light
oh i can see i just need him to come in
there is that all right good shots
what happened over there i don't know he
just walked up i wasn't even the mark
wasn't moving no light no nothing it
just was pissed i was on the other side
of the map
power offline restart reactor in zone
90. is that a thing we do with the
terminal or that thing this is not zone
90 yeah this leads to 90. 89 then 90.
i'll open the door here so if you guys
move over lights off
there's a terminal here do we need that
not for anything right now
so you know things this room clear wait
one more no no no it is not one straight
east of us and then off to the right i
see three four so far off to the right
deep one down
i see a red i said tentacles tentacles
in here
[ __ ] getting a paying off right now
okay oh that's bad understood all right
so i don't know what we're working
towards but there are five six
signatures ahead right now there's two
over by me okay
oh whoa whoa what was that where is that
oh no no no no he's far he's far he's
far jesus he's he's deep into the next
area around this corner possibly through
a door not sure but i can hear him
he pinged
i can't even re-ping him so he's pretty
far right now
okay i'm gonna get this guy hang on this
is gonna help us he has one not too far
past him
glowies
there's one guy right over there
oh hey i see him oh there's two here
he's not even in this room the guy on
the left uh squid's not in in this room
he's in there but there's like there's
like eight
there's two over here in here of just
regulars then
charging
bob can you come over here yeah yeah
i got the guy on the right that's in the
glow i got one guy on the left i thought
i heard another one i'm trying to shop
is there another one over here doesn't
look like it go
nice
is that it
oh no there are no two dots they're down
below i see one right right
right here oh god chill chill chill
reping the tentacle
is in the other wake awake awake awake
okay
we're good maybe one of them these are
so ominous there's still one above or
below got it okay this leads to 88c
which leads 88 to 90. i think that's
this is probably where tentacle is yeah
we're good in here tentacles i tend to
please i'm actually gonna take these
glow sticks is it really the grossest
demigod tentacles
better than testicles
[Music]
i was too quick at the draw
hey wasn't there uh wasn't there a box
over this way that i neglected to open
because it was a hacky hacker
dude
all right oh they're not getting a ping
off on him and then coming to help you
he's pretty hard right
i see three too close together the right
two of this group are close together
you're sort of headed off towards the
one on the left i see the two yeah i'm
getting this guy
oh there's a third
like
at 105 east
he's coming
he's coming closer uh he turned he
turned he turned he turned we're good
i'm gonna get this guy clear these
carefully
okay stop hold on
oh please don't be down watch that
please
i got three over here sean there's these
two together there's one further down
yeah i'm gonna go through the further
one bob or mark you wanna get the other
guy right next to me mark's coming
okay i have a wall between me and the
guy in the middle i'll get the middle
guy okay i'm in position on the guy
closest to me let me know when no
charging
oh careful
back to me come to me watch out for
potentially behind us they could spawn
behind us whoa hello
yeah i hear big guys behind us
my sentry's down
all right this doesn't go back there
oh ping behind locked behind
okay
[Music]
go walk through the sentries let them do
the work
like come into the other room it'll hit
them from behind too
there's also a high ground in here we
can use up where i am
that's two different strategies
uh well they're going for you two who
didn't run back through the centuries
we're fine we're fine this is fine
we're in a dead end
chill
chill chill just like we drew it up
i keep trying to put my sentry down when
[ __ ] goes sideways and i'm like
where is it how do i do it
who's the door i guess
eggy
what's this look like bob
nothing threw it directly
no no scans whatsoever oh my god no
gross fog from that kid
two uses
uh
everyone's about even me and you
yeah
it's about even uh ammo two probably one
of you other dudes oh we're all pretty
stuffed up it's me i guess we're all
pretty good i would say sean for one of
these yeah i'll give it to sean
either me i'm gonna light her away
that's okay we're on the way cool
is that a bold artifact
lock melters oh dip dip son
whoa
don't have the light of a thousand suns
or was that just a really bright angle
that it caught me at got it
checkpoint hey
nothing through this door
this level's so easy yeah man
this level is a child's boy
i'm bored
with my fear and you guys also being
here but we got the other side other
than mark's life nothing nothing nothing
we're clear we're clear
long belters
i want the mine instead oh i have a
seafoam grenade honestly that i like
that
i got i love that
use ammo pack up here and a seafoam
grenade i can't hold them at the moment
i can hold that ammo pack i cannot hold
the other bomb i gotta for use ammo here
guys i got bad news
i got two five use tool refills
oh [ __ ] oh and i have a two use med and
a four use wait where was the did you
ping the thing where is the thing right
behind you right right
here
we going down oh [ __ ] i've literally
looked at it okay
oh god i've got two i've got a six use
med pack and a four use med pack we just
gotta check and we're fine oh dear
goodness me yeah we got two sample pack
five used ammo pack [ __ ] few shoes
there's two five use tool kits
oh i almost just ran off the edge and
died that's no jealous
you dudes with toolkit stuff that gets
used up look uh bob you wanted the
scanner
yeah didn't i just gift you the funnest
fun and that you've ever had then how
about that so i'm pretty nice friend huh
that's pretty cool you're right pretty
good guy right so much more fun than you
it is true pretty epic guy i don't know
what to do with all this stuff
we try and die and then figure out what
to do after so i i now see why there was
that long narrow bridge
leading into here
oh good yeah that means we have to do
something about that i well what i
imagine is they're going to come to us
what if i did like uh
uh
all right
well i guess we're on the clock now yeah
i guess yeah we're on the clock now
that's just like force in the hand what
exactly are we are we doing that we're
on the clock now i think it's it's like
a
it's a we're starting the reactor there
was a there was a level like this in one
of the earlier rundowns yeah okay so the
reactor thing was in there or whatever
yeah i'm actually going to put my turret
i guess let's start it i'm going to put
my turret this way hit him in the back
that should be good emergency director
shut down a waiting manual restart
command there's a terminal there one of
you tech nerds do it i bet it's a
four-person scan i'm gonna bet oh i'm
gonna come over there you guys ready do
it yeah
man all right we're going
man how could you have predicted a
four-person scan in this game
pretty good i bet it's a four-person
scan that moves vertically so we have to
keep climbing and climbing
what is this oh boy it's done it's easy
there's code there's gonna be codes
someone's gonna have to do reactor
reactor unstuck is the code you have to
type who's typing it i can run back i'm
going to hide down here and try and get
a forward scan without hopefully taking
too much damage i mean i really don't
think you're that much farther ahead
than we are up here yeah i know
you you said you knew what to do so all
right i'm doing the thing
oh
it goes a little bit louder it's getting
a little bit louder
wait wait for the beat drop guys
no code yet probably at the end of this
i'm waiting for the reactor situation
looks like aliens right now
yeah pretty cool we're really set up
here for not much to open ah guys my
scene is waiting wait did we well we did
send the guy back with the scanner too
oh they coming
we get some mercs yeah yeah yeah i was
trying to get more of them in frame
all good
okay pretty well
okay
this isn't so bad this is easy
this is i love this what's the trouble
here
this is so simple like nothing bad is
even gonna happen
big coming through
is that uh do you wanna snipe him no no
actually
doing its thing there's another one
though you could talk about that yeah
uh i'm gonna head to the terminal
that's about to be happening
uh some broccoli on the right whoa
you're right they did
uh
verify code fish got it fish fish
i hear one
thing
yep
hit him sniper sentry
i have a cool nickname now yeah
got it
you've always been sniper century what
do you mean
i how do i do this what the hell reactor
underscore verify
underscore fish or space fish oh it's
kind of a [ __ ] okay thank you there we
go i mean you had to ask before you even
tried it i was trying stuff but i didn't
think it would be on the same line the
the proto the syntax is usually
underscores instead of spaces so
this is a video game i have the media
packing up it's a video game written by
coders who know how to code c4 is
running out
[Music]
pretty [ __ ] quick though despite the
seafood yeah wow nicely picked dudes
more and more and more good ball pop
way better than a pistol i know right
bulbasaur's dope
old office what's up i actually was
reading the wiki and i was looking at
stats and guns
oh you got it okay looks good here some
coming in i don't think they were
prepared for us to be so good at the
flyers well we're two out of four let's
not stroke our [ __ ] yet
dude my [ __ ] is fully out
there's your yeah but just don't stroke
it i'm headed back i'm headed back i'm
not going to [ __ ] the code up so badly
this time yeah
can you grab a tool while you're back on
the way
back uh i'll probably restock my sentry
after this wave
actually yeah of course there's a whole
[ __ ] i'm gonna do the code and then i'm
gonna find a tool yeah yeah it's in the
back like uh
there's two little boxes on the map in
the back that's where it is
nuke nuke got it i missed one coming
through on the left
yep
nope
oh our lights went out
[Music]
okay i am looking for the tools looking
for the tools
you said in the back on the left yeah
yeah if you look on the map there's two
little boxes it's in one of those okay
okay okay i'm picking up my center
five
oh wait i'll get the ammo pack instead i
do win one
i do mark one
we haven't really taken too much i'll go
get that i'll do you one more mark
actually slam me i think yours is doing
good work i don't think you have enough
time to i don't know if you have enough
time
i'm gonna get
go for it you guys got this it's all
right i'm not even gonna bother trying
to put it behind him
he was probably doing amazing damage
from behind him but whatever coming back
with some scans for you boys well let's
have a four use med pack if we need it
we've got a six use med pack too so we
got lots of med oh jeez we out here we
good
give us a challenge this is cool
i need seafoam bob whenever you want to
top me up
oh my god
right now
get back
[Music]
all right i'm gonna try and get a scan
off before all hell breaks loose big
shooters big shooters
i will help
adam one dead both dead both dead should
i throw this some seafoam great way out
there no yeah yeah actually well if he's
way out there yeah right down in the
middle how far can you throw these
things i don't know about as far as that
divider idea
where they are now without that divider
you can throw all right here
[Applause]
some are getting through right i'm
falling back right there's sea foam
there
got through the foam somehow magically
not dying all right i'm heading back to
terminal
yeah i'm going terminal okay go yeah
we're clear here somebody read somebody
read me the code i'm gonna be in the
tournament we'll all shout it at the
same time
did you get it no no i did not get it
you know what that was not a good system
yeah i know what i typed was sucked
s-u-c-k
that was not my favorite system for this
all right man sure be honest i've got
some critiques
hi
last one we're gonna hit him with the
yate
nice oh splooch that's a pitiful little
seafoam grenade
it looks right it's best it looks so
small in such a large hallway
it's how you use it here they come
oh
there's something nice
dude my sentry's a good shot
dude
triple kill
bam
man you really should have loaded up my
sentry bob
it's racking up the kills
oh god
oh jesus fly
and they're gone shoot her shoot her
dead
okay ah that was that was clean
cleaned up
they haven't done anything the turrets
are just moaning down yeah well one of
them
yeah but then i did say that the sniper
turret is dope as hell but it did change
well it's good to have both because he's
misses a lot of the smaller it's good to
have both
oh god
there's your pings boys
oh here comes flyers lots of players why
do i have to reload
fire things coming in
oh there's a lot i'm falling back to you
guys yep come back up come to us
i'm going to the terminal fall back to
the door if you need to do with the
flyers we're okay we're okay
we're okay my turret is officially out
i'm just gonna pick it up
okay
okay this should be the last one but i
hear a wave coming
uh what is this
underscore verify and pull
p-u-l-l got it all right
we did it
everybody is
good we're doing all right oh we can go
through the door now oh something's
coming we got more big
fast big i think it's just one guy's
stuck can you scan
i don't know it's not big
i'm getting gray hit markers yeah i
don't know what this means
get back get back get back get back get
back
whoa
what where's a good place to hit this
thing
i think it's back it's back it's back
the back
hit it in the back oh god how [ __ ]
grimy
yeah hit the bat don't let it lick you
for the love of god those are the we
have any phone grenades no no
yeah it's got the big bulbous things on
the back
i'm doing it all right
okay shoot her back put his back
okay we're getting it
shoot his backhoe
okay i am officially out of bed i can't
heal everybody
so who all needs help get him get him
boys get him dick suck it why wait why
is your turret still orange oh it's it's
out i was like oh it's still detectives
like a phase two on this thing
he's cool you know yeah that was
different where's his body where's the
music still playing
yeah why is i don't know it's obnoxious
oh it might just be the sound of the
reactor running it might not be music oh
wait so i think i still need to restart
the reactor oh oh yeah wait we we have a
waypoint like 200 meters away the green
the green thing was the thing we were
carrying right
i think we got the lights are on that
means the reactor's running so i think
we're good initiating reactor startup
sequence don't do it again yeah i know
did this thing just break what happened
no let's just go the power's on well
it's literally restarted
all right all right the power is on he's
not wrong let's go like it's not telling
us what the i guess download the genome
database from alpha one
lights are on everywhere i think we're
good i hear the hollow though i don't
know what that is
oh what
every once in a while there's a little
like in the background i don't know what
that little dangly thing on the ceiling
was yeah
little testies kind of look like a big
tongue it sounds like an egg sack
i thought it was like it could be all oh
there's a big guy here i forgot about
him oh yeah hey there's two big guys in
here yep
yeah we can careful we can go right
there's more than two there's more than
two we can go right by them we don't
need them
who's coughing me i ran down the stairs
why'd you do that
i didn't know there were stairs oh
god there's a bunch in here there's a
bunch
we're fine we're fine
oh yeah the whoa what the [ __ ] i thought
we killed these things or did we sneak
mine
is this the ones is this the ones that
we just didn't do
i think so
oh three of them yeah there's a bunch
there's a bunch of
i think we just need did you get
infected with
maybe how do i oh no there's a 15
infection you're going to lose down to
85 now there's no way we definitely hit
that one this just really yeah what the
hell this is just
there's a lot there's a lot over here
that's what we were saying what were you
saying
i i wasn't even to the place where you
were wade
don't move
wait
don't i'm not moving
i literally haven't your flashlight's
don't worry i can snipe them
oh god my gun was not reloaded
wow
damn it my flashlight was on how am i so
stupid so much of the time
it happens
that dead
one more that's the last one
oh what a dick
come here you [ __ ] [ __ ] damn it oh my
god die
i'm sorry bob i can't believe i left
your flashlight on
unbelievable
unbelievable all right we need
well i don't know what we need this goes
to 94. is that where we're going
flashlight's off
flashlight's on we need alpha one i
don't know what the hell that is alpha
one
the top left main objective is download
gmo database from alpha one okay
yeah dude oh checkpoint scan
hey
oh
activate air filtration zone 94. we need
to find so down the stairs
there's one and then a group of three
but we can't go down the stairs we go to
fogs do we need to move fast because of
the contaminants that was just the
wording thing you're just going to get
infected we should nominate one person
to get infected
we need to clear this i have an
infection reducing things but 94 is
we're in 91 94 is
probably just as far as we went to that
like other room yeah as this place is
were there any fog repellers
we have not seen a single fog right
i should i had an infection resist like
uh stimulant stimulation
knife no no it was 99 it was at the
beginning i thought about equipping it
but i did not oh well i think we just go
i say we just shoot and kill him here
because i'm not go i don't want to go
through the fog and wait any longer than
we need to
all right do we have eyes on items you
can snipe them first i can't once they
start moving i can scan them
all right
someone fire a shot
hey look guys
is
there's a shooter somewhere in the back
careful yeah big shooter biggest shooter
oh yeah i don't just alter them
no that's one big
that's all we got
no it's behind the server
come here show yourself show your
beautiful face wow
it's like battlefield
i think that'll help
okay
i see another walkway over there i think
i run
up above oh god oh it's amazing oh it's
amazing oh [ __ ] wait okay i'm following
this uh we've already gone oh we cannot
all right i'm following how do i get out
of here come to me come to me stare up
stand right here come right here right
here where i'm at the top of the stairs
come to me come to me can you meet me
okay
i see another scanner nothing on the
scanner
there's a there's a stair on the left
side right there you see
so we got to go through and to the left
and then
like
oh good god
okay okay oh my god what the [ __ ] okay
here we go
yeah two three to the left
94 right here careful
my eyes are all scratchy
sleepers
don't make a sound
you got you got three more over there
speed dicey
there's one more deeper in the room to
your left right now guys fog repeller
he ducked his head right when i swung oh
my goodness he's fine you're fine it's
fine oh my god good job we got ammo here
too but i don't i've already got ammo on
me
i i need ammo sean needs ammo
oh we need a key god
well there's a you only lose health down
to however much you're infected yeah
you're not going to like die but that's
yeah well i'm infected 36 percent oh no
you're i'm involved
oh that's not that's not
good well there's a lot
okay
there's a function that's true yeah let
me come over there with you where did
swan just go
there is a disinfection pack but with
only one use
and i don't know if it's in the next
room or what
yeah he's here oh yeah that is right
there
i don't see anything else should i just
take him out
if you can sure there's another tentacle
you gotta be joking me
he's over he's way over to the that way
mark yeah yep yeah this one in here mark
there's one in here use your words guys
there's the tentacle in the room that
you guys are entering and there's a
tentacle off to the right as well the
one in the room you're entering is not
pinged and i i lost them on the scanner
there's a big to the left there's a very
big there's two bigs to the left
oh joy of joys
what does this camera do what does this
do what does this door do class 4 alarm
these are the only two guys in here we
can maybe take them out if we can get
around behind him is there another door
that would like
what if i just shoot him uh what about
the tentacle man
what's going on he's in another room
right well let me close the door first
all right so you said there's one in
here
these it's through this alarm door
there's one it was it was pretty far
away okay
i shoot them both shoot them kill them
kill kill kill
target acquisition
my skirt more like my shroud there's our
friend mr tentacle dude she's over there
okay there's only one entrance to this
area
i don't have a seafoam there's a seafoam
grenade i saw over
here yeah seafoam grenade
we could see foam it up wait do you want
to put your sentry outside yeah i can do
that it's only got 11 percent though
better than nothing better than 90
percent put it back here and aim it at
the door uh it'll shoot the door if that
and it'll destroy the door aim it across
the door like uh yeah like that
so there's a tentacle in this next room
through this door
if we do this is it gonna alarm that guy
i hacked that already i mean
perfect opportunity to take care of it
if it does because yeah because there's
no other scans and it's right here like
it's literally right there
we want to open that door and i'll try
and snipe it real quick sure
[Music]
oh
you're pushing it
what are we doing he's pushing he's
drunk he's pushing the fog
i'm the fog
poison while we're in that loop yes
oh oh
guys does it stay gone all right i'm
gonna close these doors up and i'm gonna
no it does not stay gone it's [ __ ]
useless all right can you like drop it
on the ground does it work if you said
it
yeah but i also had a fog repeller oh it
turns off if you set it down
all right what is this
[Music]
really useless technology
who's here
oh [ __ ]
oh boy
[Music]
there's the first can coming in spicy
okay that's not too bad
over here
split
i got this where's it going
okay
they're gonna be close to breaking
through that door door's going down yeah
i'm gonna shotgun the hell out of this
spot insane
oh that was awesome didn't work though
it didn't work no i got hurt
ow
okay watch out you guys are shooters
they're shooters
all right uh on the left side careful
okay all right
all right all right it was easy not bad
not bad not bad
i'm completely out of century
well welcome to my world oh there's a
tentacle guy in here right nothing and
no no yes no yes
i can't see him i can't see him i don't
know i hear me slapping all right
there's a tentacle guy right there
do i chance it on shooting him there's
no one in here just shoot him just shoot
him
yeah no take it take it take it so this
is the zone we need for to reset the
thingy right this is no this is not 94.
this is 92. there's a key somewhere that
we need okay right god dang it okay uh
nothing on the scans ahead
we have we seen any terminals can we oh
wait wait bad guys down in the fog
beneath this sorry
bad watching have not seen terminals
oh yeah there there there are four
down here
whoever's got the the fog
come on they stopped
oh
just shoot him
couple more oh there's a lot there's a
big boy
watch out the door next to me is going
down the door next to me right side door
okay this is way worse than i thought
big shooter dead
other big shooter tripped and fell down
and i missed
all right hi already good god
why did that door break down oh there's
more coming out more more
ow i thought you were dead bro
all right
i would have been way more careful if i
thought there was that many yeah those
were not on the skins at all
okay well let's be a team player here
man you lay off him he's going through a
lot right now oh yeah a lot more when
i'm done with him no anything here
not
[Music]
why are you carrying that this way
that doesn't need to come with us why
did you bring that uh all right i guess
how long have you been carrying that for
i mean i dropped it
nothing no some scans ahead careful this
room is not safe okay there's one to the
right here it's two possibly to the
right around uh down this hallway this
thing doesn't actually make noise to try
to hold the hold no i think it's just
indicating it's working okay move
there's no way that wakes them up right
you guys left that would be very
[Music]
all right uh nothing on the scans ahead
right now on my boobley
safety boys keeping us safe from the
stinky fog
wait where the [ __ ] are we going we got
an ammo pack
no this is a dead end i guess this is
the dead
i'll pick it up okay we need to go this
way i'm drawing on the map i didn't see
what you drew but i'll follow you yeah
yeah follow
me ish
you know where you go follow mish
these friends
follow me nose
what would you say
i missed my wave projection five used to
refill i'm gonna use that on me and
yeah oh there's not much
i take that mr mr dicey don't move for a
moment
yeah there you go
i heard i saw you dropped that i thought
we were dead
we're not in the death smoke right now
well speaking of death smoke
seems like we got a pocket
here dude yeah bad guys bad guys bad
guys lights out lights off
saying it for myself and wade mostly
wade it's just one of the last murdering
sleepers oh
oh he's up top yeah
there are more in our area but uh
one down here
whoa whoa something's awake heads up
heads up heads up oh no tentacle
tentacle oh
uh well let's clear it i'm gonna take
care of him how many more are in here
three eyes
around us oh on here
oh yeah too late heretic
there might be another no
okay well
is this done we don't have time for
plans we fog we stab
you just fogged
stab uh is that guy gonna get us
he's not on the scanner he's not close
okay okay okay
don't walk towards it though well where
else am i supposed to go i just hang out
for a second he's licking and whatever
you have a sniper shoot him in this dick
i can't see [ __ ] well let's get closer
then
he is closer he's now 20 meters away
careful okay these tend to clean all
right i'm gonna come come this way i'm
gonna see if i can get a shotgun
and
go
i don't you're gonna get one
shot in the ass no wait wait wait wait
wait wait wait wait wait shoot him shoot
him sean you are literally standing in
front of his ass
sorry i have the bug it's a it's a large
it's a large
it's a large can't snipe it just give me
a sec
what
i'm in front of him now i need it stand
in front of him what do you want
dad nice
damn it
how how how are you going where are you
going stop moving so fast is it a hurry
i i'll put this down i can make one of
you carry it okay
no you're the knifer oh what you uh
bob's got a knife oh we're moving no
more still more scans more clear
for the moment where are we upstairs
maybe less fog
i wish you guys had better
brain
collective brain
our collective one brain yeah
that's over this way
are we walking now
okay all right
now
uh med kit here but we'll save it for
later i'll hold on to it guys i just
gotta say we're proud of our teamwork
well we gotta until this team until you
start yelling at each other oh oh oh oh
bobby you want to do it
sure
purple 537 purple 537
[Music]
okay
yeah maybe down here maybe maybe down
here all right guys i think it's down
here all right maybe down here
okay maybe i just have to say the the
proximity mines look really cool
strapped on your pack
like i just wanted to give you a
compliment it's not fine but do we all
have a mine or is it just on our two two
of you have them i think right yeah
three of us have one
hit everyone everyone but me oh my light
is off don't worry there's no one close
there's someone off two off to the right
not super close oh wait this is where we
were if we go right there's more
[Music]
oh [ __ ] yeah how do we get up i mean oh
i can climb this stuff here we go here
we go okay careful careful careful
doesn't matter you're right
there is a bagel
watch out watch out watch out don't
don't don't you do it wait don't you do
don't you judge you [ __ ] don't you
[ __ ] do it don't you [ __ ] do why
are you [ __ ] doing it well you're
doing it you're doing the thing why you
[ __ ] doing it
someone inside me is doing it okay stop
doing it whatever you're doing literally
stop doing it
why are you still doing it
i literally have not moved i don't think
they're moving i think it's fine they
are moving because this guy was jumbling
for so and i see them on my screen just
bouncing up and down
no it's it's like a glitch when you're
stoned on that you you go up and down
i wasn't moving can i move now
wait yeah
very mixed messages
yeah they were there's a big guy though
okay should we just snipe this guy's
either yeah there's nothing else on the
scanner
[Music]
i thought that didn't work
oh get it get it oh get fogged on i hope
this leads somewhere and not a dead end
yeah i'd be really sad if that was all
just purple
sanitation where do we go
i don't know i'm just a big weenie baby
holding a bigger baby i'll hold it i'll
take a turn let me have it let me have
the baby
ah
all right now i get to go on my way
i don't know i
i'm in charge you all be a little kinder
a little nicer program when i had it i
wasn't in charge a little nicer i guess
you should have taken charge i guess you
didn't know that
this is all kind of yell at me this is
like the same direction
this doesn't go anywhere where the [ __ ]
do we go wait what's where do we go mr
charge here here here on the map here
there's a door that we didn't open here
biscuits we got to go back
follow me
oh [ __ ] run it's time to go
it seems so hard
oh my god we are going
yeah well just just wait until things
start happening and then we'll see how
you like
follow it around we switched directions
there what is this door i've never seen
this before
leads to 93.
this opens
[Music]
uh i feel i've been doing this trash
away there
all right what never did that again i'm
not taking it
[Laughter]
bob you're in charge
well i have the scanner good job bob
wade your microwave projector's here
oh i should carry that [ __ ] yeah i carry
that you carry that somebody somebody
carry that [ __ ] i got a scanner both
i'll carry it
there you go you can be in charge all
right it's just [ __ ] out of here i'm
out of here
being in charge yeah the privilege
you're officially in charge oh that's a
tentacle man
i thought they were extinct
yeah we're oh god
hey you got the hot potato
no crotch in that
fog boys come here no
or stan
look at me do i look like i need fog
repelled no yeah
oh
he's clear no no it's not clear
he's behind a wall cam down non-fog boy
all right fair enough she got it you got
me there oh there's behind this one
though
class five
oh boy i saw this thing it is in this
room i saw it it is in this room i just
want you to know that yes bob please
please
what wade
oh
yeah you're right that was my bad okay
better
[Music]
oh god
are we centering on this side of the
door then before we open this alarm uh
yeah oh i'm not [ __ ] okay
i thought i triggered the door should i
put the how do i trip mine well i've
never used the trip line you just put it
down somewhere you think they're gonna
put it in you know where they will run
through you put it on the other side of
the door that's going to break right i
should put it by your turret no i'm
going to put mine by my turret
where am i going to put mine you put it
on the other door that's there there's
two doors okay
you lose weight
welp mine just bugged and placed
sideways down here and i can't pick it
back up oh
well all right that's a
that's a waste
no it doesn't work that'll work no
wait that might set off though okay yeah
if those two are there it should set off
okay it should be fine all right let's
close these doors and let's get this
entry this one should i have this behind
the source i aim this over toward your
door just to the side of the door across
the door for once would you do whatever
you want yeah wait why you why are you
asking me i don't know i just i want to
be told what to do be my dominatrix
daddy i mean to be fair if he does
anything else we're probably going to
yell at him so now i know
now we can't yeah i did yell at you for
even asking what to do so they uh
m stands for moving no it doesn't
get in guy guys guys
are we going to see from the door why
are you holding that bob we don't have c
phone oh i have c phone never mind
kaboom that sounded explodey
oh
oh good
moving moving it didn't it didn't uh do
the whole thing
okay
wait where is it it's all over the place
there's tons of them
okay they're at the door
okay they're about to break through i'm
gonna shoot oh these are these are
bugged on my end when i sit in them they
don't they don't work
hello wait what they're done they're
done
i'm still seeing circles no i have a
full person security yeah we got a full
personal security skin oh [ __ ] i don't
see that
on me just stand up yeah stand here
is it working
[Music]
oh my game is bugged it's moving back
this way same direction more
the circle's back here bob
circle we are not next to you bob
i'm i'm moving i'm moving
uh there are a bunch coming with me
they're a bunch of like following me
left side left side big scan big scan
incoming
the shooter left side
oh it's down to the fog do we have a fog
thing
fine we're not getting fogged here
coming coming i am not a zombie don't
shoot me
oh close i'm glad you said something
reloading damn this
keep firing [ __ ]
where's our skin
oh the fly boys
no
one over there there's one over here
i'll get him
don't worry oh no wait no he's over here
first one gets him gets 10 bucks
yeah i'm mine
i got him i stabbed him first the
money's all mine i did it hey my
sentry's empty
another last guy
my century's got four balls
go get your sentries look how close
tentacle boy is over here well be ready
to shoot him my friend well there's
others fans i don't know about i mean we
need to shoot him i guess oh well we
can't be ready to move
[Music]
that one's not showing up on the scanner
on the right
i see him i think he's real i know he
might be real why wouldn't he scan i
don't know oh i can't oh okay coming
left guy come left we could have told
he's right
there are two of them together now all
right
here
they showed up on the scan this time
wait they don't get me here do they no
no no
i can get this guy they just get me
there's two of them close together
very curious oh there's going to be one
less
nope he's not
yeah you got it no
oh my god are you done
you have the balls of a much larger man
than you no that was stupid oh my god
i have an idea
i'm gonna test it out
i don't like this plan this is a bad
plan do you think there's a lot of
little dudes in here by the way you
think should i go for this one are you
on christmas show can i uh if he passes
you first you can get him but i'm i
think he's gonna walk across i think you
should get him okay if i just set this
here
[Music]
do it
oh my god we did it
oh yeah and it woke up every [ __ ]
thing in the comments oh no no no but it
was dope as hell
okay
it was pretty cool there's still an
alarmy dude in here though the other
tentacley guy oh god watch out
this is kill that kill that kill that
quietly other other room it's in the
other room guys
i'm just as good as bob
i don't know about that i think of all
the things we learned from that it was
not that sentence that you said but it
was stupid
where the key is are we in the sector
where the key is yeah 93 that's what
this is yeah okay so what is it i'm
gonna ping it uh purple537 nope no key
no ping i i it should have pinged but i
didn't
there's tentacles in there
jesus i was just getting a peek
there are three of them in there
oh wow there are wow mark's on my side
he likes both moves right here i heard
it i heard it wait people agree with me
do it one more time shouldn't there also
be a visual thing yeah there is but
there are there there
54 meters away down that way oh anything
it's right in this room
oh boy they're not they're not
particularly close unless there's one
that's not showing up on scanner for no
reason
i'm just circling out like an absolute
badass
i got it i got the technique down now
all right
look mark
uh disinfection kit anyone higher than
56 uh probably not oh wait wait wait
wait wait wait wait wait wait wait wait
wait wait wait wait wait wait wait
i got you guys i think it's time for me
to show you what a knife can do
oh [ __ ] dude
yeah yeah
you just can't let anyone have it can
you
you can't be normal for five minutes i
wasn't born normal i was born
exceptional so
that i wouldn't say that the opposite of
normal is exceptional exceptional
wow oh god it is by me isn't it
it's a sleeper
perfect knife i can't get it guys i'm
right here could get a [ __ ] ball
straight i can weave through these
tentacles you can take away my triple oh
i'm just killing myself
with this knife
[Music]
i got a box over here
[Laughter]
the [ __ ] is wrong with people god i
don't understand we've gotten very fast
at this game yeah yeah yes in four hours
and 20 minutes we finished a level and a
half
every compliment turns into negativity
because we are ass
i i thought i killed three tentacled
dudes nothing can ever pull me down
again
we need foggy to get back yes
dude foghorn leg
fog boy do we yeah we gotta navigate
back through some juiciness don't we i'm
literally standing next to the door
i'm pretty sure we're putting the key in
the door
i need it i'm activating the door
oh i'm not sure a bad idea i'm just
gonna put that out there
it's a checkpoint
oh okay good thank god
there are a bunch of white signatures
through this door bunch of dead
signatures more like it
there's there's two like five feet away
from us
what the [ __ ] guys you just aren't on my
level
i'm not
literally next level on this [ __ ] right
now what the hell i'm exceptional oh
that's one is this where i need the wave
projector should i be bringing this
think this now the right way to bring
that yeah
wait what's that
stand up wait if you just stand up and
come in here you don't take damage just
stand up don't crouch okay but be
careful because there are sleepers over
here oh can you get him if i run at him
uh well that'll happen
um
here they come
they're dead
no they're not there's more they're not
dead
they're not dead
there are more there are more
hey
there's one on me i'm going to go down
uh no you're not my guy
thank you
okay we chill we're fine we're fine
that could have gone better but that's
fine
my game is bogging out like crazy right
now i think yeah i know [ __ ] out like
mark literally teleported through that
door on my screen yeah and stuff is like
frozen on my screen half the time all
right so input air filtration startup at
terminal should i do this is there any
reason
definitely gonna be a horde but
go for it i mean so we want to set up
yeah i'll put my 20 sentry over here all
right i'm putting my sentry down then
we're good let me put it right y'all no
actually yes actually
the door we didn't realize it's in here
you said there was another door in here
and i
didn't put my sentry down
oh
why did you say there was another ah
there's infection
it was jokesy oh okay
is the infection thing on the other side
of the door too oh no all right you know
what i'm just going to do like this and
if it shoots me it shoots me
it's fine
let me let me try this again it's too
easy to not do that hang on what about
this really across the room oh beautiful
just don't get hit by that that's good
it's a good spot we're going lance all
right let's do it oh [ __ ] me i'm gonna
stay behind these definitely not
explosive blue things oh transport the
wave projector oh we're good
no horde huh
[Laughter]
his turret's on the other side
all right
music playing it turns out it was the
benny hill theme all right
the whole facility i think is probably
defugged right that's the thing
that's not hopefully the idea yeah oh
yeah you guys are like seeing all these
veins and whatnot it's cool right pretty
cool yeah i've been at 30 percent not
going too fast i've got the wave
projector now you're fine you're fine
you can't sprint yeah thanks man
no mark are you going to like a place
where you i don't know i know that this
fog is not here anymore so i'm going
downstairs
that's where we were going right
i right behind you
wow it's oh non-fogged
actually it's kind of more foggy yeah
it's kind of fun
no it's more it's hazy uh we need to go
to e6
where
is that
like here
no yes no no no no no it's 84 down 91
left yeah we're 85.
is it up in 87 north in 87 possibly did
we miss anything let me query the door
because you can
you can query doors
okay where's a console oh i found it
guys it's here oh hey it's a six alarm
it's a
sweet lord wait that's more than five
and four
yep oh but it's the stairs these are fun
if you guys turn it like at the bottom
of the stairs and then we see foaming if
we have any left after we did the whole
door to boggle yeah yeah it's great it's
great it's a great view
next thing last week
yeah no this is this is like the same
stairs we have already done once
well this is all the seafoam i have
wait where are you putting your turret
at mark i'm just gonna put it like right
here
basically just to be able to cover it
you're right let's cover the backs of it
because we're going to be at the top of
the stairs so they should stay at the
bottom of the stairs for the most part
i'm going to be right here not take us
down these stairs it's going down the
stairs it's going down the stairs oh hi
i'm picking up my century oh my god
oh my god nothing on the scans something
on the scans nothing on the scans
something wrong
oh something on the scans things on the
scans now this is a long one
oh
both sides both sides both sides i got
this side
wait hang on there's one
damn it [ __ ] you
stay in the circle
ah what the [ __ ]
you don't have a head how do you lick
[Music]
i don't see the circle in it's going
down there
okay i'm just placing it here our
turrets are an ass position i i put mine
down just to put it i don't know
a little better they come here we don't
need all four here they come
wow oh i got stuff on the left
all done
going down
okay where's the next one okay it's
going down yeah down
oh my god come back
oh it's a full team one oh okay come on
come in come and come and come
oh behind you
coming
my sniper got something
all right this is at least number five
right
whoa to the left left
oh not that oh i need to use an ammo
pack i'm not oh no i don't want it
full sun yep it's over here
okay
oh well
in the distance
[Music]
coming fast coming fast
one
two three four
i'm counting my shots out so i know when
i'm out
now we gotta come back up circle this
back up okay okay we're coming maybe
oh [ __ ]
oh i'm gonna go now i'm down i'm down
okay i got trapped in a corner we need
everyone right no we don't have this one
wait wait trouble
whoa
oh jesus
hey my god this is probably it boys
[Applause]
okay well here i go
you got it oh there we go
oh oh my god okay well turret's in a
different position maybe
yeah didn't expect that
[Music]